Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so Sherlock season
four is getting ready to start on January
1 on the BBC and PBS.
So I'm teaming up with my friends at BBC worldwide
Just explain what's going on and everything
that's happened so far, so sure like is finally
back the first episode is going to be airing
January 1 on the BBC and PBS in the United
States each episode after that episodes two
and three, there's three episodes total will
air the week after that.
So January 1 January 8 and then the 15th so
it's been a long time since you've watched
or you never watch Sherlock and you have no
idea what's going on.
I'm in a recap, like the first three seasons
and the specials.
Just explain what's been happening and what's
going on no worries no spoilers for season
four and I'll add links to the trailers that
they posted on the Sherlock YouTube channel
at the end of this if you never watch Sherlock
before Benedict Cumberbatch, you probably
know is Dr. strange little movie that just
came out, Martin Freeman was also in Captain
America Civil War.
So this kind of the Marvel and the Sherlock
reunion happening at the same time.
Here was really funny before season one aired
there weren't that many people outside of
the UK that knew who they were, but it was
almost like the big seismic shift after Robert
Denny Junior started doing Iron Man Marvel
movies like suddenly, everybody was paying
attention to them.
So they just blew up big time.
Although episode by episode, but largely season
one just the coming together of Sherlock and
Watson like the story of how they first met
in how they started solving crimes together.
Moriarty didn't really manifest till the end
of the season season two was more Moriarty
heavy, but because of the way they structure
episodes some of them will be mythology episodes
where you have like this overarching storyline
of Sherlock versus Moriarty and some of them
will be more stand-alone like hound of Baskerville's
alleged of the episode starting with episode
one a study in pink Sherlock meets Dr. Watson
for the first time.
So the main adventure of this story is Sherlock
and Watson solving a series of murders where
people seem to have died by taking a poison
pill they find the person that's behind the
pills that's compelled these people to take
these is actually himself being controlled
by Moriarty in a very Princess bride poison
standoff between Sherlock and the serial killer
he is saved by Watson, who shoots the serial
killer proving what a bad ass he is, but there
lauded his heroes by the police department
they sort of prove their worth and are allowed
to continue solving cases the episode is a
brilliant job of setting the characters up
explaining their personalities.
You literally meet Sherlock for the first
time as he's beating a corpse, but the whole
idea here is just then beginning their day
to day of solving mysteries Watson blogging
about it.
He has a block in the original Arthur Conan
Doyle stories that the episodes are adapted
from Watson in a very meadow way is writing
the stories after they've happen so is your
reading the adventures of Sherlock Holmes
it's almost like it was written by Watson
himself.
So on the TV show the form that takes is the
blog that begins to take offs over the course
of the first couple seasons.
They turn into Internet celebrities which
they later turn into a big twist in season
two, which I'll explain in the second the
second episode the blind banker is more of
a deep dive into Sherlock deciphering codes
and symbols you start to learn more about
the mine Palace is an international smuggling
operation.
He finds out that the blind banker himself
was killed because he stole something in the
process of smuggling illegal goods so Sherlock
runs afoul of a gang called the black lotus
tong then later we find out that Moriarty
was again pulling the strings under the name
of someone called M. So at the end of the
episode.
We still haven't seen his face.
The third episode great game is the first
time we actually get to see Moriarty in the
flesh he finally steps out.
This is where it gets a little meta-because
Sherlock has to recover some secret government
plans for very important project but at the
same time is challenged by Moriarty to solve
a series of crimes were he's rigged different
people with exploding vests if he doesn't
solve the mystery they go boom Sherlock finally
learns how they're all connected recovers
the plans, but in doing so it throws him into
Moriarty's path.
So just as Sherlock is getting ready to blow
them all up to defeat Moriarty Moriarty gets
a phone call from someone that ends up being
a season two teaser for that first episode
that I'll explain the second but they've had
their first standoff, the unstoppable force
meets the immovable object is sort of a rain
check that they give each other on the apocalypse
that they were going to rain down so season
two episode one we learn that Moriarty when
he was talking to Sherlock what they're getting
ready to blow each other up was Irene Adler
who was calling him because she had leverage
on one of the royal family members.
So the episode is all about scandals.
There's the smaller plot getting the scandalous
photos of the Royal back from Irene Adler.
But then it becomes something much bigger
because Irene Adler has evidence of a huge
government cover up in going back and forth
of the episode.
We learned that Sherlock and Irene Adler have
a weird sexual obsession with each other,
the kind of continues in the background in
future seasons another big change.
Now during season two is that because Sherlock
is aware of Moriarty he's ever present in
the episode he sits across from Sherlock.
He taunts him there playing their game.
Eventually they capture him, but then later
release him in the second episode episode
two hound of Baskerville's more of a standalone
episode not so much about Moriarty even though
he is and he gets released, but it's mostly
about this chemical weapons program that Sherlock
finds out about that has the acronym hound.
So that's where the hound of Baskerville comes
from episode three the Reichenbach ball.
Now that Moriarty's been released from the
government facility.
He's free to go after Sherlock and forces
him to commit suicide or else all of his friends
will die.
So Moriarty is created a situation whereby
he kills himself but his agents will still
kill all of Sherlock's friends if he doesn't
throw himself off the building.
So Sherlock has to come up with a plan to
fulfill the terms of that bargain while at
the same time not killing himself.
So season two to season three was this big
mystery because Sherlock seemingly killed
himself.
He stepped off the building at the end of
the episode, then they cut to black.
So earlier I mentioned that Watson's blog
turn them into Internet celebrities.
This is where they pick up with the blog coming
into season three.
There was like a short episode where Sherlock
was like hey everybody, I'm back.
So season three, the mystery was how did he
survive, in part of the fun of the episode
was the idea that this colt of the Sherlock
had risen in his absence, everybody thinking
that maybe he's dead maybe he's not that he
or all the different ways that he could've
survived.
So it's been about two years that everyone
thought that Sherlock was dead.
Watson's moved on with his life and he is
now engaged to marry more stand they're getting
ready to get married.
So if you don't know her she's a big figure
from the Canada becomes Watson's wife and
helps him as he's writing the adventures of
Sherlock Holmes, so Mary becomes a big part
of the season three cast and all the episodes
she has her own secrets that we learn about
over the course of the three episodes but
she becomes a very important figure in what
used to be this two-person partnership, so
a lot of the comity flows from Sherlock just
getting used to their being like third wheel
now in their little group that eventually
we learn about a new overarching villain because
Moriarty is arguably dead like Sherlock saw
him shoot himself in the head.
So there's still a lot of theories about how
he could possibly survive, but the new big
bad of season three was agustus Magnuson this
sort of evil media baron who just had control
of tons and tons of information and also had
a mine Palace, like the ability to hold and
process information just as well as Sherlock.
So he slowly manifest they don't really face-off
to the third episode the second episode the
sign of three is more of a comedy about the
wedding of Marion Watson, but at the end.
Sherlock learns that Mary is pregnant.
They all learned that she's pregnant.
So the baby itself becomes this ticking time
bomb that's getting ready to go off and series
for but the final episode is Sherlock versus
Magnuson this big bad for season three, so
his big thing is blackmail he has this media
empire like imagine him being the head of
something like Facebook, so he has all this
information that could hurt everyone he uses
it to get people to do what he wants people
in positions of power people in Parliament.
The only recourse Sherlock can find is to
kill him before he can harm anyone else so
Sherlock is now a murderer being arrested
and carted off but at the very end, there's
this teaser as Sherlock's being flown away.
They make you feel like this is the end of
the partnership.
This is the end of Sherlock but just as the
plane is getting ready to take off everywhere
all over London a message of Moriarty pops
up on digital screens just all over the city
saying did you miss me.
So the government is forced to bring Sherlock
back to help solve this new mystery but then
in real life because there was so much time
between season three and now season for, which
were getting ready for of Sherlock.
They did a Christmas special last year instead
of doing new episodes but it was like a full
episode, so the teaser was is that they were
doing and episode of Sherlock in full.
In 1895 with all the same actors all the same
characters you normally sure.
Like I said in present day.
It was really just like everybody taken back
to the 1890s and they were going to do a Sherlock
mystery but then the end the big twist is
that we find Sherlock has been inside his
mind Palace this Whole Episode Is Taken Place
in Sherlock's mind with him trying to learn
how Moriarty could have survived because we
thought he was dead for the entirety of season
three, so now part of the fun of series 4
is going to be answering that question in
the first episode like what's going on who's
the new villain what was happening with Moriarty's
picture popping up all over London simultaneously.
So what can happen is is I'll be doing videos
for each of the episodes but here's the thing.
Like I know you waited a long time for series
for to get here, but the episodes are a full
90 minutes which is basically like a small
movie for each episode it's you just way bigger
than a normal episode of an hour-long drama.
So if you've never watch Sherlock before it's
kind of like watching a movie for each episode,
so there's a serialize plot the sort of runs
in the background of each of the episodes
like Sherlock versus the big bad, but then
within each episode there a bunch of smaller
ministries that he has to solve.
So I donated tell you how fantastic Benedict
Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman are the two
amazing actors, especially when they're doing
Sherlock.
So you never watch the before I would recommend
you watch at least a couple episodes is to
get yourself ready and then watch series for
starting on January 1.
So like I said I'll be posting episode videos
in the official Sherlock.
YouTube channel will be posting a bunch of
clips and behind-the-scenes stuff interviews
with the actors on their YouTube channel will
post links to that at the end of this what
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here to rewatch the season for trailer, on
their channel and you can click here for all
the other interviews and behind-the-scenes
stuff they been posting.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you guys tonight!